Javier Arévalo presidente del poder
judicial de ese país le acaba de pedir a
la presidenta Dina boluarte que las
fuerzas armadas vigilen la sede
judiciales del Perú para evitar nuevos
ataques que pudiesen afectar los
procesos judiciales alrededor de 14
locales han sido afectados en diferentes
regiones del país el vandalismo asaltó y
prendió fuego a las Cortes y esto
obstaculizará la justicia que esperan
recibir miles de peruanos Javier Arévalo
no puede precisar qué expedientes han
sido destruidos pero no descarta que el
crimen organizado el narcotráfico la
minería ilegal y el terrorismo estén
detrás de los atentados a la sede
judiciales las edificaciones han quedado
dañadas equipos electrónicos y
expedientes destruidos el jefe de la
justicia peruana Espera que la
presidenta boluarte atienda su pedido
porque es garante de la seguridad
interna y del orden en el Perú alrededor
de dos decenas de bienes públicos y
privados han sido asaltados y quemados
en los 18 días de protestas comisarías
patrulleros aeropuertos
momentos mineros y cortes en medio de
los disturbios que exigen la renuncia de
la presidenta de Dina boluarte Mientras
tanto las demandas continúan la
superintendencia de transportes reporta
74 puntos de tránsito interrumpidos 18
días nacionales afectadas y diez
regiones impactadas por los bloqueos